The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, let's
launch right into it.
Jacob and Uri were inspired
by the echo channel
to try out a simulation of what
I'd put on the board last time
or on my slides.
So what you're going to
hear is Jacob's message
going into the echo channel.
Remember, that was something
with a unit sample response
of the type delta n plus.
And actually, I
think in their case,
now it's 0.999 delta n minus 1,
so it is something like this.
Sorry?
Oh, n minus 4,000, OK.
And so you'll hear the
original message, I think.
You'll hear the message going
through the echo channel.
And then you'll hear
the message cleaned up
with the receiver filter.
That's just the inverse filter.
And then you'll hear what
noise does to it and two
flavors of noise, I think.
ECHO VOICE: This is a test of
the 602 deconvolution system.
If this is a real
deconvolution, you
are instructed to go
as quickly as possible
to the frequency domain
to make an assessment
of the effectiveness
of this approach.
This is a test of the
602 deconvolution system.
If this is a real
deconvolution, you
are instructed to go
as quickly as possible
to the frequency domain
to make an assessment
of the effectiveness
of this approach.
[BELL DINGING]
PROFESSOR 2: I'm just going
to increase the delay,
so we can hear the
echo more clearly.
ECHO VOICE: This is a test of
the 602 deconvolution system.
If this is a real
deconvolution, you
are instructed to go
as quickly as possible
to the frequency domain
to make an assessment
of the effectiveness
of this approach.
PROFESSOR 2: So you can
all hear the echo in that.
And the next one will
be it cleaned up--
ECHO VOICE: This is a test of
the 602 deconvolution system.
If this is a real
deconvolution, you
are instructed to go
as quickly as possible
to the frequency domain
to make an assessment
of the effectiveness
of this approach.
PROFESSOR 2: So
this was just one
in deconvolution, assuming
the channel had no noise.
The next one is what
happens if there's even
a small amount of
noise in the channel--
so little that you couldn't
hear it in the echoed signal.
ECHO VOICE: This is a test of
the 602 deconvolution system.
If this is a real
deconvolution, you
are instructed to go
as quickly as possible
to the frequency domain
to make an assessment
of the effectiveness
of this approach.
PROFESSOR 2: So you can hear
the noise building up because
of the deconvolver.
If you actually had noise
at a particular frequency,
you end up with an even--
ECHO VOICE: This is a test of
the 602 deconvolution system.
If this is a real
deconvolution, you
are instructed to go
as quickly as possible
to the frequency domain
to make an assessment
of the effectiveness
of this approach.
PROFESSOR 2: So one of the
difficulties with deconvolution
is it can be perfect
if you have no noise.
But even small amounts
of noise can really
mess up the deconvolution.
It magnifies the
small noise sources.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, great.
Thank you.
And that was a few
lines of MATLAB, right?
Same thing can be
done in Python.
All right, we continue.
So we're going to talk
today about spectral content
of signals after having spent
some time on the frequency
domain--
the frequency response
of LTI systems.
Let's get this up here.
So we've talked about
frequency response.
You've seen the definition.
If I give you the unit output
response of a system over here,
you know how to compute
the frequency response.
And then we went through
how you can go the other way
with the DTFT to
compute the frequency
response and the inverse DTFT to
compute the time domain signal
from the frequency response.
And what we said
last time was that
what you're doing with
a unit sample response,
you could actually
do with any signal.
So you can take
any signal x sub n,
compute from it the DTFT,
the Discrete Time Fourier
Transform, with
the same formula.
What you get is this object
that can be used then
to reconstruct the signal--
again, the same
formula, all right?
So there's just a
change of perspective.
There's nothing different here.
The key observation
now, though, is
that the formula on the
left, the inverse DTFT,
is actually allowing us to
represent x sub n, the time
domain signal, as a weighted
combination of exponentials
of this type.
And the reason
that's important is
that we know how to deal
with signals of that type
very easily.
We already know
that if you have e
to the j omega n going into
a system with frequency
response--
h omega, so an LTI system
with that frequency response.
Let me make this a
specific frequency omega 0.
What comes out is the frequency
response evaluated at omega 0,
multiplying what went in.
All right?
Nothing more
complicated than that.
So what now if
you had an x sub n
going in that was a weighted
combination of terms
of this type?
And I'm going to take a
weighted combination that's
actually a continuum.
It's not just a finite
number of terms.
I'm going to actually take
this particular weighted
combination.
So over some interval
of length 2 pi,
I take a weighted
combination like this.
So this is going over all
frequencies in our interval.
Let's take minus pi to pi.
I might as well write
in minus pi to pi--
keep it explicit.
You can think of this
as being approximated
by a sum in the usual fashion.
I'm not going to write this out.
But we know how to
approximate integrals by sums.
What the sum will
have is, for instance,
a typical term of the
type e to the j omega 0n.
And the weight that multiplies
it will be x omega 0 d omega,
right?
So we think of x omega
0 d omega as being
the amount of the exponential
at frequency omega 0
that's in x sub n.
So here is a representation
of how the signal is made up.
So then what would you say
is the output of the system?
If that's the input, and
this is an LTI system,
what's the output going to be?
Any ideas?
Somebody?
I thought I saw a hand.
No ideas?
What if instead of this, I had
a1 e to the j omega 1n plus a2
e to the j omega 2n going in?
Suppose that had gone in?
What would be coming out?
Folks, we're just two
weeks from a quiz, here.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: So can
you tell me explicitly
what I would get in this case?
If this was x sub n,
then y of n would be?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: a1h.
PROFESSOR 1: Is
it just omega, or?
STUDENT: It's omega 1.
PROFESSOR 1: Omega 1, right?
It's the frequency response
evaluated at the frequency
that you're interested
in, and then
e to the j omega 1n, and then
the response to the other term.
This is what
superposition is about.
So that wasn't so hard.
What if instead,
x sub n is given
by a continuum of
such exponentials?
Integrals are essentially
linear combinations,
but taken to the limit, where
it's not just a finite number.
So I'm not asking for
a proof of anything.
I'm asking for your conjecture
as to what the answer might be.
This is how math is
done, by the way.
You conjecture what the result
might be based on gut instinct,
based on well-educated
intuition.
And then you go back
and construct a proof
and hide all your tracks.
But engineers like to
work with intuition,
and often will stick with that.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: OK, so what would--
can you give me the
explicit expression?
What's your guess?
This is going in.
It's a weighted combination of
exponentials with weights that
are given by x omega d omega.
So--
STUDENT: So you would get x
omega d omega [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR 1: Times what?
I didn't hear the last piece.
STUDENT: Times [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Where's
the j omega coming?
What's the j?
I'm missing-- oh,
e to the j omega?
All right.
So start again.
Oh, you don't want to?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
You're on the right track.
You got us started.
Anybody else?
I could show it to
you on the next slide,
but that will take all
the fun out of it, right?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: OK, it's
probably that I didn't hear.
Can you tell it to me?
STUDENT: x omega [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: X omega times h
omega or e to the j omega n?
What did you say?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: I'm willing to--
omega n times [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR 1: That's still
the part that went in, right?
Now it's got to get mapped
by a frequency response.
STUDENT: Yeah,
that's what I said.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, so
maybe you'd said that,
and I didn't hear it.
But now we've got
to assemble this
over all possible frequencies.
Well, we have the 1 over 2 pi.
Maybe this was said already,
and I just couldn't hear it.
All we're doing is
we're saying here's
a weighted combination
of exponentials going in.
The weights are given by
the x omegas or x omega d
omega, if you want to
think of it that way.
So what comes out
is the combination
of responses to each of those.
These are the things that go in.
For each frequency, you multiply
by the corresponding value
of the frequency response and
do that for all the frequencies
of the input.
So this is just applying
linearity and superposition.
So if I compare that with this
expression, which just tells me
how the time domain signal yn
relates to its DTFT, right?
This is just writing
the same thing for y
that I wrote for x over there.
If you compare the
two, what you discover
about the DTFT of the output?
Where's the weighted
combination?
It's whatever multiplies
e to the j omega
n in this expression, right?
So it's just going to
be h omega x omega.
So we've done a
complete analysis
of the input-output
response of the system
for essentially an
arbitrary input with just
a simple multiplication.
So look what we've done.
We've taken the input that
we were given, computed
the DTFT of it, which gives
us the spectral content,
and I'll spend some time
giving you intuition for that.
That's the spectral content
of the input signal.
What we've discovered is
that the spectral content
of the output is the spectral
content of the input scale
by the frequency response.
And once you have the spectral
content of the output,
you can reconstruct
the time domain signal.
So the big difference here
is there's no convolution.
You're just doing
a multiplication.
Instead of doing y of n
equals h convolved with xn,
we're just doing
a multiplication.
So once again, you see the
convolution of the time domain
maps to multiplication
in the frequency domain.
All right, so we'll build
up to the story again.
Let's get some intuition
for spectral content.
And let's take a
particular example.
So suppose I have an x of n
that's a one-sided exponential.
You've probably done things
like this in recitation already.
So this is a signal
that starts at time 0
and then starts at the value
1 and halves it each time.
So it's a discrete
time exponential.
And so what's the DTFT?
Well, you're going
to some from m equals
minus infinity to infinity.
But actually, this only
exists for positive--
for non-negative time.
So you're going to
get 0.5 to the n.
Or let's keep it at m.
That's just the definition.
Isn't it the definition?
I'll just use the definition.
So you can now sum an
infinite series here.
And what do you get?
You get 1 over 1 minus
0.5e to the minus j omega.
This is just summing a geometric
series because each term here
follows from the previous one by
multiplying by the factor 0.5e
to the minus j omega.
So it's a geometric
series with that ratio.
And so this is what the
sum works out to be.
So if you wanted to figure
out the spectral content,
you first compute the DTFT.
And then the most helpful way
to get a feel for the signal
is to look at the
magnitude of the DTFT.
And that's what's actually
plotted in this case.
This is taken from
somewhere that
used slightly
different notation,
but we'll talk through it.
What happened to the
top of my slide, here?
OK, it doesn't matter.
What I've plotted here
is the magnitude of x
and the phase of x.
To get that, you'll actually
have to convert this
to magnitude in angle form.
I'm not doing that for you.
I'm assuming you've had
practice or will get practice
in recitation.
But the result of
that is a magnitude
that looks like this and a
phase that looks like this.
The horizontal scale, just
to make the point that this
is a periodic object, just
like frequency response,
it actually goes from
minus 4 pi to plus 4 pi.
But the interval of interest
is really just minus pi
to plus pi.
All right?
So it's just that
central portion
that's of interest-- similarly
here, minus pi to plus pi.
And then it replicates
periodically outside of that.
So we didn't really need to
show it to you outside of that.
This is just to make the point.
Another thing to observe
is that the magnitude
is an even function
of frequency,
and the phase is an odd
function of frequency.
So these are elementary
checks that you should make.
If you get an
answer that doesn't
satisfy those properties,
you've gone wrong somewhere
along the way.
If you look at the
top plot in this set,
the top plot is exactly
a signal of that type,
except I've chosen
a different number.
Instead of 0.5 to the n times
u of n, it's something else.
But here's a geometric--
sorry, a discrete time
exponential or geometric
series.
Now I've just plotted the
DTFT from minus pi to pi
to show you what the spectral
content of the signal is.
And I'm just plotting
the magnitude.
Ignore these labels.
These are the same
figures you saw earlier
for little h and big H.
I'm using them again,
except now I'm thinking
of this as a signal,
and this is its DTFT.
This is a signal, x sub n, and
this is its spectral content.
The relationship is exactly what
we had with frequency response.
So where is the spectral
content concentrated?
Is it at low frequencies
or high frequencies
or intermediate frequencies
for this first example?
Concentrated around
0, so you'd say
it's concentrated
at low frequencies.
There is content
on all frequencies,
though, so this doesn't dip
down to 0 anywhere else.
You have to assemble a
combination of sinusoids
at all frequencies to
construct this signal here.
Here is a signal.
I've had to change
the horizontal scale
because this is a signal that
evolves much more slowly.
Again, I can ask what's
the spectral content of it?
I get something which has
a peak near 0 frequency.
So it's only got low
frequencies in it
and has very little
high frequency content.
You can also start to
develop ideas for how fast--
how high a frequency you
ought to expect to see here.
So for instance, what's
the fastest wiggle
that you see in this signal?
About how long does it take to--
if you were thinking of
underlying sinusoids,
what's the fastest wiggling
you're seeing over here?
Well, to my eye, this kind of
rises and curves within about
18 or 20 samples, right?
So this might be a half period
of an underlying sinusoid.
So if I thought of
the period as being--
these are just
rough calculations.
But it helps you understand
what we mean by spectral content
and helps you as a way
of checking answers.
But let's see.
If I said 18 was approximately
a half period of an underlying
sinusoid, and I don't see
anything faster than that,
period is 2pi over omega 0.
So I'm saying that's
approximately 18.
So the frequency
that I expect to see,
the fastest frequency there,
is 2pi over 18 or pi over 9.
Is that roughly consistent
with what we're seeing there?
Does the spectral
content drop off?
Well, here is pi over 4.
Here's pi over 8.
Somewhere on pi over
9, we've run out
of underlying components.
It's because the
frequency content
is limited to that range that
the associated signal doesn't
wiggle any faster than this.
Here's another
example-- a signal
that actually--
well, in this case,
it seems to have some fairly
regular periodicity to it,
and then it damps out.
By the way, in all these
cases, I'm assuming--
actually, in all
these cases, I'm
assuming the signal's
identically 0 outside--
outside of what
I've shown you here.
If you take the
DTFT of this, you
find that the spectral content
is what-- low frequency,
mid frequency, high frequency?
STUDENT: Mid?
PROFESSOR 1: Mid
frequency right?
Because this is low frequency.
Here is 0.
This is high frequency.
This is just a reflection
on the left side.
So at some
intermediate frequency,
there's a peak in
the spectral content.
And again, you can go
through the rough calculation
I just made.
So we see some oscillation here.
Let's see.
Let's estimate the period.
That's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Let's say it's about a period
of 5 for those oscillations.
So 2 pi over omega 0
is approximately 5.
So omega 0 is
approximately 2 over 5 pi.
So we expect to see a spectral
peak somewhere around 0.4 pi.
Here's 0.25 pi.
Here's 0.5 pi.
We're about right.
So make these sorts of checks.
Yeah, question?
STUDENT: So for that
first calculation
with the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, sorry.
Yeah, I should have
done twice this, right?
What I did was estimate--
thanks for catching that.
I estimated at about
18 is the half period.
And so the period
I should have had--
36 here.
Good.
This is all ballpark,
of course, but no reason
to make it worse
than it has to be.
Vibrating, right?
And that's not exactly
where it sits down there,
but it's in the right region.
Now here's the part that we've
already seen on the board.
Once you know the spectral
content of the input,
you can assemble-- or you can
think of the time domain signal
as being made up of
those components.
Correspondingly, that's
what the output is.
And all we're doing
is invoking the fact
that this is an LTI
system for which we
know the frequency
response gives us
the output for
exponential inputs.
And then we compare
that with what
we expect to be seeing
for the DTFT of y,
and we make this conclusion.
So this is exactly
what we had earlier.
One thing to keep in mind, the
DTFT, the frequency response,
the DTFT--
these are all complex
functions of omega in general.
Each of them will have a
magnitude and an angle.
So make sure you understand
why the magnitude of y
is the product of the
magnitudes of h and x
and why the angle of y is the
sum of the individual angles,
all right?
It's basically the fact
that for a complex number c,
you can write it as
the magnitude times e
to the j angle.
So that's really what's
being invoked there.
So really, what the story
is about-- we've done
a lot of math along the way.
But this is really the story.
And I've only exposed
a little part of it
for you because I've only
dealt with DT signals.
But the same thing holds
for continuous time signals.
A huge class of
such signals can be
written as linear
combinations of sinusoids.
And when I say
"linear combination,"
it could be a combination
of a discrete set, finite
or infinite.
Or it could be a continuous
combination of exponentials
or sinusoids under an integral
sign, but the idea is the same.
If you've done 1803, you've seen
this kind of thing happening,
at least for periodic signals.
And then the other
piece of what we rely on
is that LTI systems are very
easy to understand in terms
of their action on sinusoids.
So once you put these
two pieces together,
you've got a very powerful
way to analyze LTI systems.
So just to go back to
the kind of example
I had last time, in,
which you'll be--
or you're already
dealing with in the lab--
we're talking about an
audio channel, for instance.
The frequency response, in
this case, is the magnitude.
Some characteristic here--
this is a bit of a cartoon.
But let me show you more
typical experimental plots
of frequency response.
This is frequency
response magnitude.
In most of these plots, people
don't show you the phase.
Part of the reason is,
or maybe the major reason
is, that for audio,
the ear is not
all that sensitive to phase.
If we were doing the
analogous thing for video,
then you'd be very
concerned about phase.
But in audio
characteristics, people
will typically only
show you the magnitude
because the phase
distortions aren't
picked up quite that readily.
So here is three speakers.
If you look on the site there,
you'll see many more tested.
This is the frequency range.
Now, I should make some
comments about that.
We're talking about
doing minus pi to pi.
We've been talking about
filters with frequency responses
that we show from
minus pi to pi.
So for instance, if I
had a band pass filter,
it would be something with--
in the ideal case,
something like this, right?
This is because
we're writing things
in terms of big omega for
a discrete time filter.
These are actually written--
the scale here is hertz.
And they're talking
about the action
on an underlying
continuous time signal.
So you actually need a way to
go from an underlying continuous
time signal that sampled at
a particular sampling rate--
let's say f of s
samples per second--
to a corresponding omega for
the underlying discrete time
sequence.
So the question is, how
does fs map to omega?
And I had a slide last time.
I haven't gone
through it in detail.
Maybe we'll have
you work through it
on a homework problem.
But this is actually
the mapping.
If you have a
sequence that comes
from an underlying
continuous time sinusoid
by sampling at fs
samples per second,
and you're doing all
your calculations
in the discrete
time domain, if you
want to think about what
that means for the underlying
continuous time domain, you
want to map pi to fs over 2.
It's not the omega
that maps to that.
It's the pi.
So for instance,
in the lab, I think
you're using 48
kilohertz, for instance,
at least for some part of
it, as a sampling rate.
You get a discrete time
sequence out of that.
You do various
DTFT-type computations--
spectral content or
frequency response.
Then you plot them on
this kind of a scale.
If you want to think about what
the underlying continuous line
frequency is, well, that's
24 kilohertz in this case,
and minus 24 kilohertz,
it's at this end.
So when you're
trying to visualize
what this characteristic is
telling you about what you're
seeing with a discrete
time sequence,
that's really the mapping.
The other thing about
these characteristics
is that people only plot
the positive frequency part.
So they ignore the
negative frequency because
of the symmetries there.
In applications, when they
give you a frequency response,
they will typically just give
you the positive frequency
part of that.
All right, so this is
what we're seeing here.
This is the characteristic
of the LTI system
that you're going to be
sending signals into.
And then you've got to
characterize the signals
that you're going
to send through it--
voice or music or whatever.
And this is a figure I
showed you last time.
But basically, you're looking
at the spectral content
of the signal of interest
and seeing how it matches up
with the channel that you have.
And if you compare with--
well, let's actually
look at the previous case
and get a few landmarks, here.
So let's take the Sony speaker,
for instance, down here.
OK, so it's got a fairly
flat frequency response
for a range of frequencies.
But you've got to get fairly
high up before you get there.
For frequencies lower
than about 100 hertz,
this is not doing a very good
job of propagating the sound.
The frequency
response is measured
by having a microphone at a
fixed distance from the speaker
in an anechoic chamber.
And you can see that
this one is actually
perhaps the poorest
of the-- it is
the poorest of the speakers
in that it does it very poorly
with the low-frequency sound.
So for this particular
one, you would
hope that the spectral
content of what you're
trying to send
through the channel
lives somewhere
in maybe 300 to--
300 hertz to 10 kilohertz--
if you want to get it across
the channel--
from the speaker
with high fidelity.
But if you've got
low-frequency signal
that you're trying to send,
and you use the speaker,
well, you're going
to be out of luck.
It's not going to
propagate it very well.
So thinking in terms
of frequency response
and spectral content
is really key to making
sense of a lot of this.
All right, let's get a little
more practice with this.
And I just want to show
you that once you've
learned how to deal
with frequency response,
there's not new stuff
that you're going to do
to deal with spectral content.
It's just a change
of perspective.
So let's see.
If I asked you for a signal
that had its frequency
content uniformly distributed
in some finite range,
can someone tell me what that
signal is going to look like?
I'm asking you for a
signal whose spectral
content is uniformly in
some range minus omega
c to plus omega c.
Have you met such
a signal before?
Anyone?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: Sorry?
PROFESSOR 1: It was the unit--
we've seen the same kind of
thing with the unit sample
response to the low
pass filter, right?
So if this was a
frequency response,
then the associated
unit sample response
would be the signal
we're talking about.
So remember what
that was called?
We called it a sinc function--
sinc function in time.
So if the spectral content
is this in frequency,
then the signal that
you're talking about
is going to be a sinc function.
Now you can actually
work that out.
You don't have to
take my word for it.
You want flat spectral content
in the range minus omega
c to plus omega c.
So the signal that you're
going to get as a result
you can extract from
this computation.
And this is exactly the same
function that we saw last time.
So the DTFT does what your
eye may not do very well.
If I had just given
you the signal
and asked you to take
a guess as to what
the spectral content
of that is, you're
not very likely to
have ended up deducing
that the spectral content
is flat in some range and 0
outside of that.
So the DTFT is
valuable in actually
doing this analysis for you.
So there is a signal that
has flat spectral content.
More examples of
a similar type--
and again, we first
encountered these
in the context of unit sample
responses and frequency
responses.
But now, I just want to
change perspective and think
in terms of time domain signals
and their associated DTFTs.
So if we look at
the top one there,
this is the case we
just saw, except I've
truncated the sinc function.
And so what I get is not the
perfectly uniform distribution
of frequencies in some interval.
There's a little bit
of a wiggle to it.
But this is essentially
the sinc function
and its spectral content.
Here's another signal
whose spectral content
is at high frequencies
and essentially
0 in the low-frequency range.
What does it look like
in the time domain?
Well, you can
actually work it out.
And here's what you see-- that
this has actually more wiggle
to it than the sinc does.
Alternate samples seem to
take opposite signs, at least
of the dominant ones
over here, reflecting
the high-frequency
content of that signal.
Here's something
that's intermediate.
This also has the
oscillation in sign,
but it's not necessarily
in alternate samples.
It's a little bit
more leisurely.
Here's something that has low
frequency and high frequency,
but not intermediate frequency.
So you see a component
that's rapid wiggling,
but you also see this
lower-frequency content
in there.
So this is what the
DTFT does for us.
Now there's an issue of
how you compute these,
because if you look at
the formula for the DTFT,
you could certainly
do analytical things
with that expression.
And that's the case that--
we've treated cases of that
type, where you write down
an analytical
formula for the DTFT.
And then you do things
with that, like plotting.
But if I gave you some
numerical sequence here,
there's certain simplifications.
For one thing, you
really aren't going
to expect to compute this at a
continuum of values of omega.
You're not really
going to expect
to construct the values
from minus pi to pi
at every real number omega
in that interval, right?
That would take you a long time.
So what you're
likely to be doing
is asking for what the DTFT
is at some grid of points.
So you'll form a little grid.
And it's on that grid of
points that you want the DTFT.
That's the only practical
thing you can do.
You're not going to compute
it at all omega outside
of toy examples like that.
So if you had a numerical
sequence collected in the lab,
for instance, this is what
you'd be aiming to do.
What's the other thing that's
likely to be the case if you've
got a numerical sequence
collected in the lab?
Any thoughts here?
It's unlikely that
my summation is
going to go from minus
infinity to infinity
because I'd be waiting
a long time to collect
that signal, right?
So in practice, what
we're dealing with
are signals of finite
duration, typically assumed
to be 0 outside
of that interval,
though you might have reasons
in some context for assuming
otherwise.
We're always going to take
finite length signals.
So the summation will be
over a finite interval.
And we're going to want
to compute the DTFT
on a finite group of points.
And that makes for
some simplifications.
So let's see here.
You've probably heard
people talk of FFT,
or the fast Fourier transform.
The fast Fourier transform is
not a new kind of transform,
so the name is a
little bit misleading.
It's a good way of
computing samples of a DTFT.
So you don't have to
learn a new transform.
We're still talking about
this object, the DTFT.
The FFT is an efficient
way of computing
the DTFT on a grid
of points, given
a signal of finite duration.
Now, I've got a lot on this
slide, and I hope all of it
is right.
But let me talk you through
the basic idea, here.
So we're going to
compute the DTFT
on a finite grid of points.
So that's the omega k's that
I've shown you over there.
We've only got a
finite duration signal.
Let me say that it exists
only from 0 to p minus 1.
So the signal is 0
outside of that interval.
And therefore, all the other
terms drop out of this.
So there's nothing
new in this formula.
This is just
acknowledging that I only
want to compute the
DTFT at a grid point,
and I only have a
finite duration signal.
Now the interesting thing
is that if your signal is
0 outside of this
interval, well,
that means your
signal is completely
specified if xn is known to be
non-zero only on the interval,
let's say, 0 to p minus 1.
So that's p values.
Then you would hope that just
having p samples of the DTFT
will allow you to
go the other way.
We know for sure
that if I gave you
the entire DTFT, if I
gave you the entire DTFT,
that you could go the
other way, because we
have this expression.
If I gave you the
entire DTFT, you
would just plug it into here.
And you'd get the
time domain signal.
What's interesting,
though, as it turns out--
and you might expect this.
Since your signal takes non-zero
values only at p points,
you only need p
samples of the DTFT
to get an exact reconstruction.
And here is the formula.
And the derivation is not hard.
I've omitted it here.
It's the same kind of idea
that we used in the full case.
But you can actually--
using the values of the
DTFT at these grid points,
you can reconstruct
the signal x sub n.
So with these
simplifications, you actually
have a simple pair that gets
you through the numerics.
If you followed these formulas
exactly as they're written,
you'd end up doing work
on the order of p squared,
because you see each
of these summations
involves taking p products.
And then you've got to sum them.
But you've got to do it at
p different frequencies.
And the same thing
on the other side--
you've got to do p products,
but you've got to do it p times.
So it's order p
squared computation.
The fast Fourier
transform is actually
a clever way of using
the symmetries associated
with these exponentials
to group the computations
and make it much faster.
And you can actually
reduce it to order p log p.
So it's a huge simplification.
I've got some illustrative
numbers down there.
So the FFT actually
is a major reason
for advances in
numerical computations,
including signal processing
of various kinds--
the fact that you can
get this reduction
from p squared to p log p.
All right, I don't
think I need to say much
about the grid of points.
But let's move on to thinking
about spectral content
of signals going
through channels.
All right, so we'll get
closer to signals of the type
that we're interested
in, which are
these signals in this
case for on-off keying
that are signaling 1's
and 0's and that we're
trying to get across a
channel-- for instance,
the audio channel.
So this might be a typical
finite length sequence.
This particular case, we had
chosen 7 samples per bit.
That's why the shortest
interval you see
has 7 non-zero bits, there.
Here's the spectral
content of the signal.
And actually, I've
taken this figure
from an earlier version
of the course, where
we talked about the discrete
time Fourier series,
not the discrete time
Fourier transform.
The discrete time
Fourier series turns out
to be something very
similar to the formulas
I showed you for the FFT.
So the discrete
time Fourier series,
apart from a scale factor,
is essentially a story
built around this relationship.
And that's developed in
some detail in Section 13.2,
but we're actually
bypassing about this term
to try and keep
the story simpler.
So when you see
these plots, you'll
see on a, at magnitude
a of k, that's
a symbol associated with the
discrete time Fourier series.
These are actually
Fourier coefficients
associated with the periodic
replication of this signal
outside.
So it's a discrete time
version of the Fourier series
you may have seen in 1803.
All you have to do when
you see a plot like this
is think of it as a scaled
version of the DTFT samples.
So we're just talking about
samples of the DTFT taken
at a grid of points.
The scale factor may be
off by a factor of p--
the length of the signal.
But the shape is entirely
told to you here.
So think of this as
samples of a DTFT.
We're going from
minus pi to plus pi.
What's down at
the bottom here is
imagining that you've sent
this signal over a channel that
could absorb the entire
spectral content of the signal.
So suppose you had a
channel whose bandwidth--
suppose I had a low pass
channel whose bandwidth
has got some cutoff.
This is low pass.
Suppose this
bandwidth could absorb
the entire spectral
content of the signal.
In other words, what I mean
is that all these DTFT numbers
that are significant
actually fit in under this.
So suppose your channel was
such that it didn't attenuate
the DTFT coefficients.
So the spectral content
is unmodified when
it gets through the channel.
And so if you resynthesize
the signal using this formula
at the receiving end, you'd
get back the same thing again,
because the channel's not
induced any distortion.
Let me go past this
and actually show you
what happens when you
start to distort the--
what goes across.
So here, what we're doing in
this succession of experiments
is sending that same
signal through a channel
with successively
smaller bandwidth.
So in the first case,
everything goes through.
There's no distortion.
You get the same
thing back again.
In this case, the
channel actually
has a cutoff that
ends up zeroing out
all spectral content outside
of some frequency range.
So it's a low pass
channel whose bandwidth
is not enough to take the
spectral content of what you're
feeding across.
So what do you expect to happen?
Well, the higher-frequency
components of the signal
have been zeroed out.
So what should happen?
You expect the signal to be
more rounded because it can't
make these sharp transitions.
It takes high-frequency content
to make sharp transitions.
So what happens is you trim the
spectral content by sending it
through a channel
that's not wide enough
to contain all of the
signal is that you
get a more rounded
signal at the other end.
So you sent this.
This is what you're receiving.
This is the distortion
that the channel
has imposed on your signal.
And you can imagine if you tried
to find a place to sample this,
you might run into some trouble.
If you go even
more extreme, here
is an even narrower channel.
What comes out is even more
rounded than what we had there
because you've taken away more
high-frequency components.
The signal just can't
wiggle that fast,
so it takes its leisurely time
going through its paces here.
And you can imagine that
you can be thrown off
when you try and take samples.
This is actually even more
evident on the eye diagram,
here.
So these are eye diagrams--
again, the same kind of thing.
As you successively
transmit fewer and fewer--
let's say less and less of
the high-frequency content
of the signal, what
gets picked up--
what gets received is
a more rounded version
of what was sent in.
And the corresponding
eye diagrams
that you construct--
well, at a certain point,
I guess somewhere
around here, you'd
be a little nervous about trying
to find a place to threshold
and decide on what
signal you have.
So this is not a noise issue.
This is a distortion issue.
It's distortion
induced by the channel.
And it can all be
understood in terms
of what the channel is doing
to the spectral content
of the input.
I think we'll continue next time
to get more insight into this
and start on the
topic of modulation.